fue en el vídeo pasado que hablamos
acerca de la desigualdad de coches wards
y en esta ocasión quiero recordar la
desigualdad de coches wards y además ver
la famosa desigualdad del triángulo pero
antes de eso vamos a recordar que decía
la desigualdad de coches wards y de ahí
vamos a partir decían tomémonos dos
vectores equis y james y estos dos
vectores van a existir en rn son dos
vectores que existen en rn y recordemos
que ninguno de los dos tendría que ser
el vector cero eran vectores no nulos y
bueno entonces la desigualdad de coches
watts me decía lo siguiente si yo me
tomo el valor absoluto del producto
punto de estos dos vectores
esto es menor o igual que la
multiplicación de sus longitudes vamos a
escribirlo si yo me tomo el valor
absoluto de x punto james esto es menor
o igual que tomarme la longitud del
vector x ya está multiplicarla por la
longitud del vector bien y es que al
final recuerda que estamos comparando
dos valores escalares porque tanto el
producto punto te da de resultado un
escalar como la longitud te daba de
resultado
y si nosotros tomamos el valor absoluto
de un escalar pues sigue siendo un
escalar imagínate que tienes un vector
de 50 componentes un vector que existe
en r 50 si nosotros calculamos su
longitud sigue siendo un número escalar
podría darnos por ejemplo 3 y bueno en
fin también hablábamos de cuando se
cumplía la igualdad y la igualdad se
cumple cuando uno de los dos vectores es
un múltiplo escalar del otro por ejemplo
aquí x es igual a cbs y se cumple la
propiedad de que no era cero porque si
se fuera cero pues que existe tendrían
entonces se es no cero y estamos
diciendo que estos dos vectores son con
lineales al igual que los vectores
solamente que ese es un escalar y
entonces decimos que en este momento
justo en esta ocasión y solamente en
este caso se cumplía la igualdad es
decir que x punto james en valor
absoluto es exactamente lo mismo que la
longitud de x multiplicada por la
longitud de jeff las longitudes de
héctor x multiplicada por la longitud
del vectorial y esto es lo que decía la
desigualdad de cosas wards y bueno
también la igualdad de colisión
en el caso en el que los dos vectores
eran co lineales y bueno a partir de
aquí quiero empezar el vídeo de hoy y lo
que quiero empezar a ver es tomarme dos
vectores y sumarlos y después tomarme la
longitud de esta suma de los vectores
recuerda que la suma de dos vectores
también es un vector y a esta longitud
elevarlo al cuadrado así que déjame
escribirlo la longitud de la suma de dos
vectores elevada al cuadrado y la estoy
elevando al cuadrado porque recuerda que
esto era exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme el producto punto del vector que
está dentro de la longitud junto el
mismo fíjate que estos dos vectores te
dan un vector y entonces esto lo podemos
escribir de la misma forma que x + punto
x + james es justo la primera propiedad
que vimos en el primer vídeo de esta
serie
entonces x + punto x + jim y bueno
recuerda también que vimos ya varias
propiedades del producto punto como que
es conmutativo o como que era
distributivo y de hecho justo esta es la
propiedad que quiera utilizar ahorita el
producto punto es distributiva así que
voy a aplicar las mismas reglas para
abrir este producto punto
bueno tal vez en el vídeo pasado le hice
un poco rápido y no quiero que te
confundas al final el producto punto se
comporta como si tuviéramos dos binomios
multiplicándose entonces para que no te
confundas otra vez déjame tomar un nuevo
color y voy a poner la multiplicación o
como se hable el producto punto por la
distributiva that de una manera bastante
clara voy a poner x + james en los
primeros dos sumandos de color amarillo
x + james punto x ma jin y bueno
utilizando la propiedad distributiva
precisamente el producto punto esto me
quedaría como x punto x magem ya esto le
tengo que sumar 10 puntos x + jr pero
este ya de amarillo déjame ponerlo de
color amarillo para que no nos perdamos
es que esté ya del sumando amarillo
punto x + james lo único que estoy
haciendo es abrir el producto punto de
estos dos mandos que yo tengo aquí lo
único que hice fue separar el producto
punto tanto para el primer sumando como
para el segundo sumando y bueno
utilizando otra vez la misma propiedad
si yo saco el producto punto de x
x más bien pues esto es lo mismo que x x
+ x ya dejamos que vivió aquí abajo esto
es justo lo mismo que x x la x de
amarillo la otra x que es de color azul
más x punto james la x de amarillo punto
la de color azul ya esto le tengo que
agregar ye punto x más pero de igual
manera si se cumpla es tribu tividad en
el producto punto aquí me va a quedar 10
x más de punto james jay de color
amarillo punto x de color azul más y
punto hoy en día de color amarillo punto
jet de color azul y bueno a continuación
me voy a ir a un poquito más rápido
porque lo que quiero recordar es algo
que ya vimos varias veces x punto x
quien es x x es lo mismo que la longitud
del vector x elevado al cuadrado esto ya
lo habíamos utilizado aquí arriba x
punto x es exactamente lo mismo que la
longitud del vector x elevada al
cuadrado así que dejamos escribirlo la
longitud del vector x
aquí voy a ponerlo la longitud del
vector x elevado al cuadrado ya no me
importa el color la longitud del vector
x elevado al cuadrado ya esto le tengo
que agregar a quienes tengo que agregar
pues tengo una vez x punto y más otra
vez y punto x pero también sabíamos que
el producto punto era conmutativo cuando
tanto x punto y punto x es justo lo
mismo y si yo sumo dos cosas iguales
pues me quedan dos veces esa misma cosa
es decir que estos dos se pueden
simplificar en dos veces x punto y 2 que
multiplica a x punto y james que al
final esto es un escalar ya esto le voy
a sumar puntos pero el punto james
también sabemos que es exactamente lo
mismo que la longitud de ye elevada al
cuadrado
la longitud de gem elevado al cuadrado
que por cierto date cuenta que aquí sigo
obteniendo un valor escalar fíjate que
tengo una escala más una escalar más una
escalar lo cual me da una escalar
bueno esto es en primera parte también
quiero recordar otra cosa aquí arriba si
yo tengo el valor absoluto de un número
este siempre va a ser mayor o igual que
este mismo número estás de acuerdo y si
yo aplico estos mismos vectores me
quedaría lo siguiente que x punto james
es menor o igual que el valor absoluto
de x punto g porque fíjate bien x punto
es un escalar pero x punto que puede
tomar un valor negativo imagínate que x
todas las componentes de x son positivas
y todas las componentes de 10 son
negativas x punto james sería un valor
negativo sería una escalar negativo y
esto es menor o igual que si tomáramos
este mismo valor pero en valor absoluto
por lo tanto esta desigualdad se cumple
un número siempre es menor o igual que
ese número en valor absoluto y fíjate
bien aquí tenemos el valor absoluto de x
punto entonces aquí puedo agregar otra
pequeña desigualdad me va a quedar que x
punto james es menor o igual que el
valor absoluto de x punto james que es
justo lo que acabamos de ver aquí abajo
y esto a su vez es menor o igual que la
longitud de x x la longitud de james y
esto por la propiedad de la desigualdad
de consensuarse y perfecto porque esto
lo voy a utilizar
bajo esto me va a servir para ya casi
finalizar la famosísima desigualdad del
triángulo fíjate bien lo que tenemos
aquí abajo tenemos dos veces x punto
james
qué pasa si a continuación un poco que
esto es menor o igual que lo que tenemos
aquí arriba en la desigualdad de corts
iguales esto es menor o igual que fíjate
bien voy a poner las dos longitudes al
cuadrado iguales y en lugar de poner dos
veces x punto james voy a utilizar la
desigualdad de coches swartz entonces me
va a quedar la longitud de x elevada al
cuadrado más dos veces déjame ponerlo
aquí más dos veces y ahorita vamos a ver
qué ponemos aquí y al final me queda más
la longitud de james elevada al cuadrado
y aquí en medium voy a reemplazar x
punto james por la longitud de x
multiplicada por la longitud de ie
porque yo sé que esto se cumple la
longitud de x por la longitud de y es
mayor o igual que x james y entonces se
sustituyó esto aquí me va a quedar que
esto es mayor o igual que lo que
teníamos anteriormente dos veces la
longitud de x que multiplica
y ahora si me vas a poder creer
perfectamente esta desigualdad que acabo
de escribir y bueno todo esto que
tenemos aquí arriba todo esto de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que la longitud del
vector x más elevado al cuadrado con
esto fue justo con lo que empezamos por
lo tanto déjame escribirlo aquí todo
esto era lo mismo que esta expresión que
tenemos aquí arriba con esta expresión
fue con la que empezamos y entonces me
queda que la longitud del vector x más
elevada al cuadrado es menor o igual que
todo esto que tenemos aquí en la derecha
y bueno ahora fijémonos en qué es lo que
pasa aquí en la derecha si te das cuenta
tenemos algo al cuadrado más dos veces
el primero por el segundo más el segundo
al cuadrado y si sabemos que la longitud
nos da escalares entonces tenemos un
escalar elevado al cuadrado más dos
veces una escalar por otro escalar más
el segundo escalar elevado al cuadrado y
esto es justo un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto un binomio cuadrado perfecto
que habla de que el primer término y el
segundo término son la longitud de xy la
longitud del yang es decir que esto lo
puedo escribir como
longitud de x más la longitud de jet
todo esto elevado al cuadrado y bueno
esto es lo mismo que tenemos aquí a la
derecha por lo tanto aquí puedo poner
menor o igual que la longitud del vector
x más elevado al cuadrado fíjate que se
cumple el cuadrado del primero más dos
veces el primero por el segundo más el
cuadrado del segundo y bueno no vamos a
olvidar la parte izquierda de esta
desigualdad la longitud del vector x más
elevada al cuadrado es menor o igual que
esto de aquí la longitud del vector x
más elevada al cuadrado es menor o igual
que la longitud de x más la longitud del
elevado al cuadrado y bueno qué pasa si
tomo la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados de
la ecuación me va a quedar que la
longitud del vector x más james es menor
o igual que la longitud del vector x más
la longitud del vector
james ya esto justo a esto es a lo que
se le conoce como la desigualdad del
triángulo cuando yo les hablo de la
desigualdad del triángulo me estoy
fijando en longitudes en qué longitudes
es la longitud del vector x más james y
a esto la estoy comparando con la
de x más la longitud de james y para
recordar que es la desigualdad del
triángulo recuerda que la longitud del
vector x may efe es menor o igual que la
longitud de cada uno de los vectores del
vector x más la longitud del vector
así que ahora me voy a transportar al
mundo del papel de las gráficas y ya que
tengo aquí las gráficas ahora sí voy a
dibujar el vector x voy a dibujar el
vector james y vamos a ver esta
desigualdad de una manera gráfica
imagínate que este es mi vector x no
estoy tomando un vector así al azar no
importa pero vamos a llamarle a este
vector el vector x y entonces lo voy a
tomar ahora el vector bien y como me
quiero tomar la suma de x + james
entonces voy a poner ahí que empiece
justo en el punto final del vector x por
lo tanto voy a decir que este es mi
vector james sin pérdida de generalidad
estoy tomando un vector también aquí
cualquiera y ahora si tienes el vector x
más bien si nosotros nos acordamos el
vector x + james es aquel sector que
empieza en el punto inicial de xy que
termina en el punto final de james
así definimos la suma de dos vectores
así que este de aquí va a ser director x
mayer y bueno la desigualdad del
triángulo de lo que me dice es que me
fije en las longitudes de todos estos
vectores así que vamos a aplicarnos si
yo pongo la longitud del vector x ma jin
mi desigualdad el triángulo dice que
esto debe ser menor o igual que la
longitud de x más la longitud de james y
si estamos hablando del plano cartesiano
de r2 esta desigualdad es muy clara
porque si yo quisiera ir de un punto al
otro la distancia más corta que hay de
un punto al otro es irme en línea recta
y no pasar por un punto intermedio
porque aquí estamos yendo a otro lugar
antes de llegar al punto en el que
queríamos acabar nuestro destino y ahora
si pensamos en cuando se cumple esta
igualdad vamos a pensar en que los
vectores también son con lineales fíjate
bien imagínate que yo me tomo a éste
como el vector x y ahora a continuación
le sumó un vector que es co lineal este
de aquí va a ser un vector james que es
co lineal y además está encima del
vector x este de aquí es mi vector
y bueno si te das cuenta si éste es mi
vector equis y este es mi vector james
la suma de x + james es exactamente lo
mismo
hablando de longitudes que la longitud x
más la longitud 10 y bueno si esto nos
hace pensar que estos dos vectores son
co lineales vamos a ver si las
matemáticas nos concuerdan así que
déjame quitar de nuevo todo esto que
tengo aquí vamos a quitar los planos
cartesianos y vamos a trabajar con las
matemáticas para ver si realmente se
cumple la igualdad del triángulo en el
dado caso en el que estamos hablando de
vectores con lineales así que fíjate
bien voy a suponer otra vez que x es
igual a cbs
es decir que uno de los dos vectores es
un múltiplo escalar del otro déjame
escribirlo aquí el vector x es igual
hace veces el vector 10 es igual a c
veces el vector gemma y bueno ahora yo
lo que quiero fijarme es qué pasa con
este 2 veces x punto james
yo lo que sabía por la desigualdad de
coches hertz es que se cumple la
igualdad cuando me tomo el valor
absoluto de x punto james y claro
utilizando que los vectores son
se cumplía esta igualdad fíjate bien
aquí dice que el valor absoluto de x
punto y es lo mismo que la longitud de x
por la longitud de james y aquí tengo a
x punto y no tengo el valor absoluto de
x punto m
por lo tanto me faltaría saber si
realmente x punto es positivo y no
forzosamente es positivo habíamos dicho
que un producto punto puede ser que sea
negativo sin embargo si yo me tomo a la
constante esta constante que tengo aquí
como una constante positiva con un
número escalar positivo entonces si se
cumple que esto es lo mismo que el valor
absoluto fíjate bien si yo tuviera x
punto james utilizando que x es igual a
cbc es el vector y entonces esto me va a
quedar c veces el vector punto en
vectorial y bueno el punto y es lo mismo
que la longitud de y elevada al cuadrado
la longitud de y elevada al cuadrado y
toda la longitud de un vector es
positiva o igual a cero entonces para
que éstos sean positivos necesitamos que
se sea positivo y si tomamos a ser
positivo entonces si en efecto se cumple
que x punto y es lo mismo
el valor absoluto de x james y es justo
lo que queríamos porque si yo tengo 2
veces x punto y estoy tomando a x igual
a una constante positiva porque entonces
me queda que esto es lo mismo que dos
veces el valor absoluto de x punto yen y
si además recordamos la desigualdad de
coches watts me dice que si los vectores
son co lineales se cumple que entonces
esto es igual a la distancia de x por la
distancia de james entonces me va a
quedar que 2 veces x punto y si se es
positiva es exactamente lo mismo que dos
veces la longitud de x que multiplica a
la longitud de jeff ojo recuerda que me
estoy tomando la constante positiva y si
me estoy tomando la constante positiva
entonces estoy diciendo que esta
expresión que yo tengo aquí y esta
expresión que yo tengo acá son iguales 2
veces x punto james tiene que ser igual
a 2 veces la longitud de x por la
longitud de james y si te das cuenta
este era lo único que nos faltaba para
que se cumpliera la igualdad por lo
tanto estas dos expresiones serían
iguales y terminaríamos diciendo que en
este caso la longitud de x
y es exactamente igual a la longitud de
x más la longitud del diente y ojo
recuerda que todo esto lo estamos
construyendo tomando en cuenta una cosa
bastante importante que los vectores
además de ser con lineales es decir que
un vector se los múltiplo escalar del
otro tienen que cumplir que la constante
por la cual está multiplicada el vector
ya sea positiva si pasa esto entonces se
da la igualdad y si se da la igualdad
entonces pasa esto sí y sólo sin que así
te acuerdas en los planos cartesianos
que yo había dibujado hace rato era
exactamente lo mismo que el segundo
ejemplo que habíamos visto la longitud
de x + i es exactamente igual a la
longitud de x más longitud de y cuando
teníamos un vector encima del otro y
bueno ya casi te estoy escuchando me
estás diciendo sal es que el álgebra
lineal parece ser un poco boba porque al
final todo esto ya lo había visto en
alguna clase de secundaria o de
preparatoria o es más que por simple
intuición yo sé que si yo quiero llegar
de un punto a otro de una manera mucho
más rápida la manera más rápida de
llegar de un punto a otro es la línea
recta pero bueno todo esto lo estamos
viendo gráfica
en r2 sin embargo lo que yo quiero que
pienses es qué pasa si tenemos vectores
en rn es decir imagínate que agarramos
un espacio de 50 10 20 100 dimensiones
lo que sí sé es que estos vectores tanto
del vector x como el vector james puedan
tener n componentes y él no puede ser
100 pueda estar viviendo en r 100 por
ejemplo y si nosotros pensamos en
vectores con 100 componentes ya no es
tan fácil observar esta desigualdad del
triángulo y sin embargo lo importante
del álgebra lineal es que todos estos
resultados los está generalizando para
cualquier en el que tú te tomes puede
ser en cualquier espacio de n
dimensiones y aunque no hemos visto la
definición formal de dimensión estoy
seguro que ya te estás imaginando lo que
es y también por ello es la importancia
que tiene esta desigualdad del triángulo
claro contando esto que está aquí que no
podemos olvidar y de hecho en el
siguiente vídeo yo quiero pensar acerca
del ángulo entre dos vectores y mediante
que nos tomamos un ángulo de dos
vectores en r2 y tomamos a decir ay pero
en r2 es muy sencillo por ejemplo puedo
tomar este ángulo que está aquí pero sí
te digo que pensemos en definir un
ángulo entre dos vectores de n
componentes ya no se pone tan sencillo y
esto es justo lo que quiero ver en el
siguiente vídeo